llanuras áridas hasta donde alcanza la
vista estamos en doñana uno de los
mayores humedales de Europa ahora casi
completamente seco
José es guía desde hace 6 años varias
veces a la semana cuenta los animales de
la zona esta zona en el caso de beber
agua tendría una lámina de agua bastante
extensa veríamos aquí flamenco cintas
especies de patos distintas especies de
garza por las aves migrantes pueden
intentar pasar por aquí pero al ver que
no hay agua buscan otros sitios
concretos donde sí puedan encontrarse
con agua debido a la falta de lluvias en
un año la población de aves quedó
reducido a una quinta parte
Los visitantes se encuentran con con
esta escena pues le produce tristeza y a
mí también pero me preocupa mucha
generación de futuras
que van a conocer doñana solamente por
los libros de las enciclopedias los
libros de texto en los colegios
estas imágenes fueron filmadas hace
cinco años en aquella época la mayor
laguna de doñana seguía siendo Un
refugio para muchos animales Incluso en
verano pero este año la intensa sequía
hizo desaparecer las últimas gotas
las zonas permanentes que tienen agua
todo el año que no son muchas son las
que permiten el que gran parte de la de
la flora y fauna pueda subsistir a la
época a la época más dura que yo quiero
pensar que podemos hacer algo todavía
otra cosa es que me esté equivocando
la agricultura intensiva es la otra
razón principal de esta desecación
11.000 hectáreas de cultivo en
invernadero rodean doñana una sola
hectárea requiere dos piscinas olímpicas
de agua al año algunos agricultores se
extraen ilegalmente miles de metros
cúbicos
Juan ha sido un activista kit durante 30
años regularmente elimina estos
depósitos de agua ilegales el pozo Está
sacando agua constantemente y la abuela
acumulan aquí de aquí se distribuye para
mantener en riesgo todo este tipo de
explotaciones
[Aplausos]
1 2 3 ahí tienes tres tres cuatro pasos
tienes ahí mira si tiene esposo ahí en
la zona esa parte de estas tierras
fueron declaradas no regables en 2014
por presión de la Unión Europea sin
embargo aquí el agua sigue fluyendo
libremente es un paso de grandes
dimensiones si podemos mirar en las
aguas están a más de 15 metros de
profundidad te está diciendo realmente
el nivel que tienen las aguas
subterráneas el gobierno de Andalucía
apoya a ciertos agricultores que están
fuera de la ordenación y apoya más al
sector económico que al sector de la
conservación de mañana
en los últimos años el gobierno español
ha cerrado 220 pozos ilegales y otros
400 están siendo revisados medidas que
los ecologistas consideran demasiado
tímidas paralelamente las autoridades
andaluzas presionan para su
regularización este representante de los
agricultores está preocupado
aquí almacenamos el agua que utilizamos
para regar durante un día los que están
ilegales se regularizan y tienen derecho
a extraer el agua seguramente a nosotros
nos van a decir que extraigamos menos
agua con lo cual vamos a poder regar
menos superficie aquí los frutos rojos
están en el centro de una verdadera
guerra del agua porque se trata de un
negocio jugoso que representa más de 500
millones de euros de facturación anual
según Manuel estos cultivos ilegales son
un peligro para la exportación esa
imagen afecta a todo el colectivo parece
de puertas hacia afuera parece que todos
Aquí somos ilegales cuando llevamos
cultivando 40 años de forma totalmente
legal y controlada nosotros dependemos
fundamentalmente del mercado Y si el
mercado decide de no comprarlo pues no
podemos producir
bajo la presión de la Unión Europea el
proyecto de regularización se ha
suspendido por el momento Manuel Mora es
alcalde de lucena
Qué pasa
Qué pasarela
su pequeña ciudad de 40.000 habitantes
es la que tiene el mayor número de estos
pozos ilegales en esta sala se registran
todas las infracciones registradas por
las autoridades españolas
una solución por
159.207 euros como estos terrenos son
públicos el municipio tiene que pagar
parte de las multas
lo que Nosotros llamamos las habituales
500 aquí detrás de milf en su pueblo que
históricamente ha dependido de la
agricultura este alcalde dice haber sido
abandonado
defendemos doñana lo que no estamos
dispuestos es que a que se ha costado de
nosotros no nosotros tenemos derecho a
permanecer aquí se pretende echar a los
agricultores no había ningún tipo de
alternativa
a cultivo alternativas sociales que debe
haberlas
para evitar nuevas sanciones en los
gobiernos central y regional acaban de
presentar en Bruselas un plan de acción
conjunto propone el cierre de más de mil
pozos ilegales pero también invertir más
de 100 millones de euros en
infraestructuras para mejorar el estado
del acuífero quizás la última Esperanza
para salvar el parque de doñana